Yeah,
part of it is blind luck taught us.
Everything is blind luck,
you know,
really just rewind everything we've said
this interview and you can add blind
luck.
Certainly in my career I've been
incredibly lucky that we say I was,
I wasn't as good as spin made me look.
It wasn't as bad as gear made me look
when it failed.
Uh,
I had a lot of great luck would spin as
well as some good hard work and some
good instincts.
So,
um,
you know,
I think luck is important even in
creativity because people walk in the
door and if they like it,
they call their friends and they walk in
the door,
you know,
sometimes you meet somebody randomly and
you say,
why don't you try writing for me?
Or how would you like to be a
photographer for me?
You know?
And it happens.
The environment though to sustain the,
the atmosphere of creativity is you have
to have the balls to risk doing
something edgy and having it failed.
I used to say,
oh,
my photographers who came to work for
me,
you know,
I said,
I love your portfolio.
Take pictures that you would put in your
portfolio.
Do not give me middle of the road
average photography that you think is
safe,
so I'll hire you.
Again.
I'm telling you,
you got three assignments.
I don't care if the first two are crap.
You still get a third.
So in that confidence,
come out and take your pictures because
that's the voice I want in the magazine.
I say to my right,
it's the same thing.
Don't get me a safe middle of the road
piece.
Give me an edge.
Eps.
Find the truth.
The truth may not be pleasant.
We'll publish it either way,
if it's true,
but go out there in the conference.
I'm still going to hire you unless you
steal from us,
then I'm not going to argue and that
happened.
But you know,
basically one has to foster confidence
amongst one's creative people.
There's nobody less creative,
less confident in the creative field.
And I say that myself is when I'm
writing,
let's conference anybody on the planet,
I'm sure.
Um,
but you must foster confidence.
People must feel they can actually go
and be artists for you.
Now,
a lot of editors and publishers don't
want artistry.
They want straightforward industrial
produce a product as to fill the space.
Don't upset your advertise.
A complaint I have about Conde Nast is
that they are more concerned about not
upsetting their advertisers than they
are about delivering a gps.
Yeah.
Then we fear will deliver great pieces
and so when New York had those two
exceptions,
but you have to foster confidence that
people can go out and actually reached
the brass ring in each assignment and
then you get critical and that begets
other creators.